I just feel like going home either end
maybe you just continue working on
myself and Jana better myself because
you like my tattoo says you can't love
someone else
it was another tearful night on The
Bachelor before the rose ceremony 25
year old real estate agent lace decided
to eliminate herself I'm mad at myself
for I have a lot of work to do on myself
and I wouldn't be able to offer any more
this experience just made me realize
that and I tried so hard and the
connection just wasn't there so I think
it's better that I go and the drama
didn't end there Jubilee got emotional
after amber confronted her for giving
Ben a massage when she already had a
rose yes I am I think there's like a lot
of tension in the house tonight some
things I think were offensive to some
girls I can't sit and walk in a show but
I like about Jubilee is that she doesn't
walk on eggshells she says things that
make me even like blush sometimes I had
a great day with you yesterday don't
doubt that in the end Jamie and
Shoshanna didn't receive roses and went
home next week the crew takes on Sin
City but more tears and more chaos ensue
I don't know I can't do this you guys